RICHARD BUERY: All
right, good evening.
So I googled from
inside Google today.
I'm very excited.
No reason, I just
wanted to be able to say
that I had done that.
I hope everyone's doing well.
Very excited to be here.
Congratulations--
ERIC SCHWARZ: Thank you.
RICHARD BUERY: --on
an amazing book,
an amazing career,
an amazing service,
in creating a great
organization, which
I have a personal thanks,
because I think we've
talked about this before.
My cousin [? Janitzia ?]
[? Rhoades ?] was one
of the first-- I think maybe
even in the first class
of Citizen Schools up in Boston.
ERIC SCHWARZ: Yasmina's--
RICHARD BUERY: Yasmina,
my aunt, my aunt Yasmina.
So from my family,
let me say thank you.
So tell me, in starting Citizen
Schools, what was the problem?
Why create Citizen Schools?
ERIC SCHWARZ: I
started it really
out of a sense of frustration.
First, let me say to
Google, thank you guys.
[? Gautham ?] personifies
what's been so amazing
about this partnership, which
started in Mountain View,
came to Cambridge, New York,
Chicago, Research Triangle
Park.
And we have like 500 people
like [? Gautham ?] who
have incredible energy,
incredible passion.
And they teach robotics.
They teach programming
an Android phone.
But they also teach-- I talked
to an 80-year-old guy who
learned engineering
at age 50 and now
is one of the top engineers
in the Cambridge office.
He teaches the history
of jazz and blues music,
and kids love it.
[? Gautham's ?] teaching a
6 Degrees Networking course
this year, and he did
Shark Tank last year.
And it's an amazingly
creative group.
So thank you so much to our
hosts from Google for having us
here.
[APPLAUSE]
But Richard, I started
Citizen Schools 20 years ago
the same reason I really
wrote the book, which
is both frustration at what
seems like a broken education
dialogue that was
kind of broken then
and is really broken now,
a strong sense that we were
trying a whole lot of things
working really hard to improve
schools, but doing it within
a box of six hours a day,
one teacher in
front of the room.
Kids learned just in
that time at school
in a sort of traditional method.
And it was clear 20 years
ago that wasn't working.
It was clear 20 years ago
that upper-income kids
like me were getting a lot more.
And now there's been
sort of an arms race
to the top in
upper-income communities.
And kids are getting
much, much, much more.
The gap between upper
and lower income kids
has gotten much bigger, even
since starting Citizen Schools.
But we also have
more proof that when
you bring through a program
like Citizen Schools
the same robotics classes,
the same enrichment,
the same extra academic
coaching, the same extra hours
of mentorship to
low-income kids,
they'll get the
same kind of results
that their
middle-income peers get.
So that was the basic idea.
Bring chances to be
successful, chances
for kids to meet great
mentors like [? Gautham, ?]
and chances to have
more time to learn.
Pretty basic stuff,
and it works.
RICHARD BUERY: And
why middle school?
You could have started out
early childhood, elementary.
You could have gone
later high school.
Why middle school?
ERIC SCHWARZ: Well, as some of
my family members and cousins
in the room know,
middle school was
sort of a tough time for me, to
the point where at one point--
RICHARD BUERY: My son just
started middle school.
Please don't scare me.
ERIC SCHWARZ: I saw
that on Facebook today.
Well, fourth and fifth grade
were kind of tough for me, too.
So your son's
probably got a leg up.
But it got so bad, my mom came
in to meet with my teachers
for the n-th time.
And my French teacher turns
to me after the session
and says, your poor
mom, your poor mom.
RICHARD BUERY: Oh,
excellent teaching.
Great teaching moment.
ERIC SCHWARZ: So middle
school was difficult for me,
and it's difficult
for a lot of kids.
It's the broken part of the
American education pipeline.
If you look actually at the
international comparisons,
our kids in fourth
grade are up there
with South Korea and Finland
and the other top countries.
By eighth grade, we're a
little below the middle
and headed down.
And I think that's because
middle school kids are, first
of all, pushing
their parents away,
so they need mentors
from the outside.
We don't do a good job of
providing those mentors.
And second of all,
they're at an age
where they need to experiment.
And we want them to do that in
a good way, in a healthy way.
They need to make things, and
get up out of their chairs,
and move, and learn in
those different ways.
And too much of school is
around sitting in a chair,
and sort of being talked
to, and memorizing things.
And that may have worked in a
1950s-era industrial economy,
but it doesn't work now.
And so we need to change that.
And the focus of Citizen
Schools in middle school
feels like the last best chance
to really get kids and put them
on a pathway to success.
And kids are old enough to
do some pretty cool things,
and they can design
an Android app.
RICHARD BUERY: You
make a powerful case
in "The Opportunity Equation,"
available for $10 in the back,
all proceeds benefiting
Citizen Schools.
You make a very powerful
case for the primary driver
of achievement gap being not
so much the quality of schools
but the differential
investments that some families
can make in early childhood
education, out of school time
learning, summer learning.
Here in New York City,
we're in the middle
of a really massive expansion
early childhood system.
Starting Monday, we're
doubling the number
of after school programs we
have for middle school students.
And there was a really-- yeah,
you can applaud for that.
[APPLAUSE]
And it was a really big
bruising political battle
to get those resources
here in New York.
And I think part of it-- I'm
sure there's a lot to it.
But I think part of it
is that for many folks,
there's this sense, somehow,
that after school is extra.
It's nice gravy.
But you make the point in the
book that it's not just gravy.
It's the driver.
How do we make that case to the
broader country, that these are
not nice to haves, but
these are must haves?
ERIC SCHWARZ:
Well, that's what I
hope the book will help
to do a little bit.
And before I talk
any more about that,
I want to say that this
guy here is amazing.
And New York's lucky to have him
in the role that he's in now.
But Rich grew up in Brooklyn,
right after Harvard--
I think right after
Harvard-- started
an amazing program
called Groundworks
that does after school
extended learning,
college prep, a whole
lot more, became
head of the Children's
Aid Society,
and then recently came into
this great leadership role
with Mayor de Blasio.
But I think you're right.
After school,
particularly 20 years ago,
and still too much
today, is seen
as an afterthought,
sort of a nice to have.
And I think if you look
at the reason for why
the gap between upper and
lower-income kids-- which
when I grew up was
about two grade levels.
There's always been a gap, but
it was about two grade levels
then.
Now it's four grade levels.
The gap in college graduation
rates was 40% to 6%.
Now it's almost 80% to 8%.
So in both cases, the
gap's almost doubled,
and there's no evidence that
schools are more unequal.
Schools are a little
unequal wealthier
to lower-income communities.
But there's a lot of evidence
that upper-income families
have tripled their investment
in learning-- from Russian math,
to Kuhlman math,
to robotics camp,
to music coaching, and
all kinds of things that
build social capital, and
build intellectual skills,
and give leadership
opportunities to upper-income
kids.
And that's what's
created this huge gap.
So I think we just need
to make that clear.
And we're not going to
stop upper-income families
for doing that.
I do that for my kids, and
you do that for your kids,
and we're going to
keep doing that.
But if we're going to have
sort of a shadow education
system delivering incredible
results to upper-income kids,
we need to find a way to
bring that, take that out
of the shadows,
bring it to all kids,
so that all kids
have the opportunity
to do similar cool things.
RICHARD BUERY: I think one
of the awesome innovations
of Citizen Schools-- besides
the name, by the way.
I have to ask you how you
came up with that name.
It's one of the best nonprofit
names I've ever heard.
But I think one thing
that's so powerful
about it is the idea of
engaging citizens in education.
And you think about
politically, and how
do you create a
movement like this,
I think one of these innovations
is that this work is really
driven by citizens.
You have engineers at Google
who are doing this work.
ERIC SCHWARZ: That's right.
RICHARD BUERY: And then there
is a power there in terms
of making this
movement move forward.
I'm curious.
Was that sort of intentional?
Did you sort of have in
your mind at the beginning
that one of the
ways you were going
to drive this work
forward is by getting
some of the wealthier,
some of the more resourced,
in society into
schools, or is it just
sort of a happy
[INAUDIBLE] coincidence?
ERIC SCHWARZ: No, it was
partly out of a personal desire
to want to teach but not
be a full-time teacher.
But I think that is something
that a lot of people feel.
There's a lot of people who
want to connect with kids.
And we're giving kids access
to Google and Fidelity
and other cool places.
But we're also giving those
engineers and those lawyers
and others access to kids who
have a lot of creative ideas
and a lot of potential.
And that's a really cool
part of the program.
It is one of our goals to
help with you, and with TASC
in the room, and others to lead
a movement so expanded learning
time becomes the new normal.
And I want to introduce--
maybe he can just stand up.
He's in the room
somewhere-- my successor
as CEO of Citizen Schools,
who's an amazing person, Steven
Rothstein in the back.
[APPLAUSE]
So if you didn't meet
Steven beforehand,
he's an incredibly
skilled political leader.
When he was a
seventh-grader in Brookline,
he closed down his school in
protesting the Vietnam War.
He knows about commerce.
He built Citizens Energy as
the world's first nonprofit oil
company.
And we're thrilled.
It's now day four,
day five on the job,
and I'm incredibly
excited to support him.
And he, I think, is
thinking a lot about,
how do we accelerate our work
in trying to build a movement?
How do we make the political
case for extended learning
time?
Part of it, I think, is
getting powerful people
from all walks of life to
have empathy with poor kids
so they don't become those
kids, they become our kids,
and they have much more
of a sense of possibility.
And the other thing that
holds back, I think,
movement on extended
learning is a sense of,
that's not going to work.
I think there's a lot of
people that say, oh, well, that
probably can't work.
That's too expensive,
or it just won't work.
And so I think we've made a
major commitment at Citizen
Schools to develop
top-shelf data, multimillion
dollar studies that
show this works.
This works as well or better
than the best charter schools.
This narrows and usually
closes and sometimes reverses
achievement gaps with
middle-income kids.
And so I think data, empathy
through getting powerful people
connected to kids, and
then just persuasion--
it's a generational effort.
Because old
paradigms die slowly.
And the paradigm
of just school is
with the teacher for
six hours, and you've
got to get kids out to work
on the farm-- we don't have
many kids leaving school
to work on the farms.
But we still have an
agrarian era schedule
and an industrial
era delivery model
that we really need
to move beyond.
Apologies to this
side of the room
for having my back
partly to you.
RICHARD BUERY: OK.
I'll talk to them.
You talk to them.
ERIC SCHWARZ: We'll work it out.
RICHARD BUERY: Can you
talk more about that?
You talked about the
investments you've made in data.
How do we know that
Citizen Schools works?
What do you actually measure?
ERIC SCHWARZ: So,
from early on, we've
figured that people
intuitively trusted
that a model where
kids get to make
cool things with engineers, and
publish newspapers, and do all
this hands-on work would
build social skills
and interpersonal
skills and a set
of things that are
hard to measure,
and that Citizen Schools really
does build in the powerful way.
But we figured people
would mostly not
trust that it built grades,
graduation rates, and test
scores.
And we were starting
in Massachusetts,
which is lucky to have one of
the best testing systems, which
isn't perfect but tends to
test higher order thinking
skills more than a lot of sort
of simple fill in the bubble
tests.
So we committed 10 years ago to
really be measured in part by,
do our kids do
better on the MCATs?
Do they finish high
school at higher rates?
Do they go into college
at higher rates?
And the first study we did
started about 10 years ago,
ended about five years ago.
And it looked at kids
just in our optional
after school program.
And they erased
the achievement gap
on passing the
MCATs in 10th grade
having been in the
program in middle school,
and they erased
the achievement gap
on finishing high
school on time.
So that was super exciting.
And now we've evolved from
an after school program
to a model where we
work with schools
to work with every
kid in the school.
So the whole school becomes
a nine or 10 hour day,
and we call it
expanded learning time.
And we think that's really the
new model for urban schools,
that every kid has a
nine or 10 hour day.
It's just if you
go to school, you
don't get out of
school until 5:00.
It's not an optional
thing to stay or go.
But it's not all
sitting in a chair,
and it's not all one teacher
in front of the room.
It's a whole second shift
of educators from AmeriCorps
and from places like
Google that come in
and really bring alive learning
in the afternoon, but also
all day long.
And we partner with teachers
in really powerful ways
to team up throughout
the whole day.
RICHARD BUERY: And just
following up on that thought,
you talked before
about things you
do for your own children,
things I do for my children.
There is a tension,
perhaps, I think.
My kids, the crap I take them
to, the art classes, sports,
and all the stuff, it
never, ever occurs to me
to sort of ask for an evaluation
of the impact of my child's
basketball program
on his test scores.
It almost seems
sometimes like we
think that the things that
our children benefit from,
that we know in our
hearts drive resiliency,
drive teamwork skills, drive
interpersonal skills, just
drive joy-- sometimes I
just feel like, why don't we
believe poor kids deserve that?
And that maybe isn't
a fair question.
But why does it always
have to be proven?
Why can't we just say--
ERIC SCHWARZ: Just common sense.
RICHARD BUERY:
--that poor children
deserve joyful
experiences out of school?
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC SCHWARZ: They do.
They deserve every experience
that upper-income kids
take for granted.
And those skills
are more and more
provably important
to moving ahead.
And part of what
the book gets at
is that while test scores,
if it's a good test,
is a little piece of what you
need, it's sort of a low bar.
That's part of it.
You need that.
It's necessary but
way insufficient
to be a leader in
modern society.
And there's a chapter
in the book that's
about social capital, what
Robert Putnam and others have
talked a lot about.
Because what moved me ahead
was not so much great grades.
I tested fine, but I had
pretty terrible grades.
But my father knew Gary
Hart, and he introduced me
to Gary Hart, and I got a
job on that Senate campaign
as a 19-year-old.
And that was a life-changing
experience for me.
And it is social capital that
moves a lot of people forward.
And some people assume,
well, that's a lost cause.
You either have it or not
based on your ZIP code
or who your parents are.
But that's not true.
Social capital is absolutely
something that can be imparted.
And the kids that
[? Gautham ?] has worked with,
they've learned social skills.
He learned the hands up thing,
but they learned that too.
But they've also met him.
And in three years, if
they want an internship
through his cool
summer internship
program-- I know Boston
has, New York probably has,
too-- they've got
someone to call.
We have many kids now
who are in college
who had a citizen teacher they
worked with write an essay,
write a recommendation for
them going into college.
So it's a whole set of skills.
It's the chance to be creative.
And one of the
biggest mismatches
between what schools are
doing and what kids need
is schools aren't
doing nearly enough
to teach creativity
and innovation.
They're still way too much
around memorizing and following
rules.
And in the old days, you could
get a good job, middle class
job, following rules.
But now most good jobs
you have to innovate
where there's no playbook.
So how do you build
the skills to innovate
where there's no playbook?
You only do that
by practicing it.
And if you don't
practice it in school,
where are you going
to practice it?
For upper-income kids, they
practice it at robotics camp.
They practice it starting
with little arts and crafts
projects or just
that music project.
My daughter went to Argentina
for three a half weeks
last summer singing.
And that probably
won't do anything
to improve her MCAT scores.
But she wrote back.
She said, Dad, I'm
living the life.
I'm giving out autographs.
We're doing these concerts,
and I'm giving out autographs.
And it made her feel
so good about herself,
and it made her more confident
in talking to people.
And that's a big
part of success.
RICHARD BUERY: That's awesome.
So I want to read one
of my favorite quotes
from your book,
which I wrote down.
There were couple
of great quotes.
But one of my favorites--
it's early in the book--
is, "How likely is it
that a child will grow up
to become an engineer if
she has never met one?"
Talk a little bit
more about that,
what the inspiration that
your citizen teachers
provide to the people
in the program.
ERIC SCHWARZ: Well, the motto
or goal of Citizen Schools
is to help every kid discover
and achieve their dreams.
And there's a lot of hard
work in the achieving.
There's a lot of data.
There's a lot of coaching on
getting better at teaching.
There's a lot of
learning from school day
faculty and a lot of trying
to continuously improve.
But it also starts with just
discovering your dreams.
And every kid has dreams
to do cool things.
But they're often
dreams that are
drawn from a fairly small
selection of career ideas
that they've seen on
TV or they've seen,
maybe, around them.
And one of the coolest things,
I think, about the program
is giving kids a chance
to work with engineers.
We have a rocket scientist who's
taught seven times over a class
called It is Rocket Science
where kids get to launch
these rockets in the
backyard of their school.
And their final WOW! event
at the end of the semester
is they're on a
hookup through Skype
with real astronauts from NASA.
And they're
calculating how to do
a simulated landing of
a rocket on the moon.
And they've got to calculate
how to do it amidst lunar
windstorms and all these
different challenges.
That opens up all kinds
of cool opportunities.
And literally, for a
black girl growing up
in the South Side of
Chicago, the chances
that she's met an engineer in
school or in her neighborhood
are sadly low.
And yet so many
jobs in the future,
so many middle to
upper-income jobs,
are going to be in engineering.
That's just one example.
And we're not a career program
to push her into engineering.
But we've got a bunch
of kids in four schools
in Chicago, every kid in
these four different schools
that we're in, now
getting a lot of chances
to work with engineers, but
also lawyers and architects
and carpenters and
a whole lot more.
RICHARD BUERY: You
mentioned the WOW!.
And has anybody here
never been to see a WOW!
at Citizen School?
All right, so a few of you.
So do yourself a favor.
Can you invite folks to come?
ERIC SCHWARZ: Absolutely.
RICHARD BUERY: So do
yourself a favor-- just
entirely awesome, awesome.
When we started
Groundwork-- I think
I see Matt Klein
in the back, right?
So that's Matt Klein.
We were starting Groundwork.
What do you think we did?
We actually studied the way
Citizen Schools was organized,
in part because you
had this great--
I just love the name of a WOW!.
You had the great marketing
and ideas to get the words,
get these powerful
ideas, across in a way
that could capture
people's imaginations.
And I'm just kind of
curious generally.
How intentional was
all of that when
you were building
the organization?
ERIC SCHWARZ: It was
very intentional.
And the idea behind the WOW!
was not just sort of a cool
word with two W's and an O.
But the idea was to have kids
do work that was high enough
quality and interesting enough
that it got adults to say,
wow, I can't believe that
sixth grader could do that.
And that was the goal.
A lot of kids put out a little
mimeograph one-page newspaper.
The first WOW!
Citizen Schools was me-- I used
to be a journalist-- working
with 10 kids to publish an
eight-page tabloid newspaper
on real newsprint and
with advertisements
that paid for it.
And that was cool.
And when people saw
that, when they brought
that back into the school, it's
like, wow, that's really cool.
Your byline is right there.
And a lot of kids might
do a little mock trial
in the classroom where
they argue about something.
Our kids go to the
federal courthouse
in front of Justice
Breyer in one case,
or in front of state
and federal judges
at this amazing courthouse.
And they're wearing their
Sunday best clothes.
The jury box is filled with
people like in this room
right now, and their
parents are there,
and their teachers are
there, importantly,
seeing them in a
whole new light.
So a kid who may be a
special needs student who
the teacher's kind of
decided, well, they're
not going to be a great
student, all of a sudden
they do the closing argument.
And the teacher sees them
in a whole different way.
So not every apprenticeship
leads authentically
to adults saying that in
the most authentic way.
But that's our
aspiration, to have
every class say, wow,
that is really cool.
And my sixth grader might
not be able to do that,
and I might not be
able to do that.
Increasingly, the kids are
doing things that I definitely
can't do, like
program an Android,
an app for Android phone.
I have a hard time
erasing photos.
I was trying to erase a
photo to clear up space,
because my daughter had taken
so many photos on my phone.
And I had to get [? Khalid ?]
to help me do it.
RICHARD BUERY: Well,
I have to say, wow.
So that leads me to another
one of my favorite quotes,
and I think also relevant to
talking about your background.
"Our job is to catch
kids doing things right."
And I know that for
so many children,
the traditional part
of the school day
did not often give children
the sense of an opportunity
to feel like they've
done something right.
And I think one of
the exciting things
about the work of Citizen
Schools and organizations
like it is you give
children a chance
to excel in a variety of ways
that they might not have.
And that's an experience
they can take with them.
I'd love to hear if you have
any great stories about kids who
have come through the
program over the years
who you feel like the spark--
the kids who were struggling
in the traditional school day
for whom the extended learning
time of Citizen Schools helped
them recapture a love of school
generally.
ERIC SCHWARZ: Yeah,
and just a quick story
about that idea of
catching kids doing things
right-- the first summer
of Citizen Schools,
we had 60 students and about
60 volunteers teaming up
to teach 20 different classes.
And one of the classes was
led by a police officer
in Boston Dennis Rory, who was
a community police officer.
And he would always show
up in his blue uniform.
And one day we had a picture
of him in his full uniform
on a pogo stick jumping around.
So he's a very joyful guy.
And he said, as a
community police officer,
the other police officers, they
kind of catch the bad guys.
That's their job.
My job and your job
at Citizen Schools
is to catch kids
doing things right.
And he taught this great class
where kids developed a brochure
around community policing,
and that was their WOW!.
And that really stuck with
us, since we've always
tried to do that.
So many stories about kids-- one
that's coming to mind right now
is a student named Jonathan
Edwards, no relationship
to the former
presidential candidate.
But Jonathan was-- his record
if you looked him up at school
would be special needs student,
D student, D's for grades
on average, probably
won't finish high school,
in fifth, sixth grade.
But if you got to
know him a little bit,
you learned this
kid loved animals.
And this bat had once
flown into the brick wall
outside of his
mother's apartment.
And he had picked the bat
up, put it in a shoebox,
nursed the bat in his
house back to health.
But he had never
made the connection
between his love of animals
and veterinary care or biology
or math.
He took a class taught by a
young doctor who had grown up
in New Orleans, followed
a somewhat similar path
to Jonathan to Harvard
Medical School.
He taught a class called
Drugs on the Brain
where kids had a chance to hold
a human brain in their hands,
dissect a sheep's brain, put
a little droplet of alcohol
on it.
And it was
transformative for him.
Because he all of a
sudden just saw something.
And he held a boa
constrictor another time.
He saw a link between
some of his passions
and a future career.
And he transitioned out of
special education classes
into regular education classes.
And we see that happen a lot as
kids who are sort of typecast
as a certain kind of kid,
who feel like failures,
discover success
at Citizen Schools.
And it may not be the
first apprenticeship
or the second apprenticeship.
But it might be the third
that they feel like, wow, that
was successful, and I build
the muscle memory of success.
And then the next time
it's a little bit easier,
whether it's another
apprenticeship,
or it's a sport,
or it's math class.
RICHARD BUERY: You, of
course, write and speak
passionately about opportunity.
This is an idea on which
our country is built,
the idea that where
you start life
should not dictate
where you end life.
And you also present
some stark statistics
that really challenge that idea.
And I think it's
troubling to really come
to terms with the fact that
although equal opportunity has
never been fully true, what's
troubling about the moment we
live in now is that you could
argue that in many ways,
we're not even going
in the right direction,
that the amount of a child's
income that can be predicted
by their parents' income
is growing, not declining.
It's fundamentally an American
idea, and one that I think
is hard as citizens
to come to grips with.
And so I guess I would ask you
where the country is right now.
Are you optimistic?
Do you think we can get on
the right path in making
"The Opportunity Equation" real?
ERIC SCHWARZ: I think we can.
I think we're seeing
it more and more
clearly work for a certain
portion of our population.
But what you say is so true.
We're living in a time, the
first time in American history,
where opportunity is actually
declining and not growing,
where inequality is
growing, not declining.
We've made some progress,
though we have a long way
to go around inequality of race.
And that gap in
terms of test scores,
et cetera, is half what
it was at the end of World
War II but still way too big.
But inequality based on
income is twice as big
as it was 40 years ago.
And there are a lot of forces
in a worldwide economy that
will make it hard.
If you get that extra
education, your services
are more in demand
and drive up income.
But the thing that
makes me optimistic
is that there are a lot
more people besides Citizen
Schools that are
doing this work.
And when we started this,
there were a few dozen examples
of low-income schools that were
lifting kids to the performance
level of high-income schools.
Now there's hundreds
and hundreds, maybe even
a low number of thousands.
We're involved in
30 of them where
it's a whole new
kind of school that's
delivering
extraordinary results.
But the National
Academies Foundation
is doing amazing things.
High Tech High out in
California, the Met School,
ExpandED with TASC.
There's some number of
schools, probably 1,000, 2,000,
that are delivering
great results by giving
low-income kids what
upper-income kids take
for granted.
So that, I think,
eventually will take hold.
The second thing that
makes me optimistic
is it doesn't have
to cost that much.
It would cost about $6 billion
to bring high-quality expanded
learning time to every middle
school in the country that's
majority low income.
That would reach
millions of kids.
It's very doable.
It won't be done in
the next three years.
It can be done in
the next 10 years.
What New York is trying now
with trying to make extended day
omnipresent-- not for
every kid in the school,
but for a lot of the kids in the
school-- in every middle school
over the next several years, and
trying to do pre-K in a big way
too, is a big experiment
on, can we do big things?
And I think that whenever the
country has done big things
from the founding of the
country through the Civil Rights
Movement, it's been
citizens in the lead.
And government
ultimately follows.
Particular people
in government lead.
You're leading, and
your mayor is leading.
But we won't be able
to do this nationally
if we don't have citizens
at the forefront.
And that's what's so exciting to
me about Citizen Schools is we
need [? Gautham, ?] and we
need [? Khalid, ?] and we need
their colleagues, along with
millions more like them,
demanding extra
opportunity for all kids.
Because Google needs it.
The other sad thing that I
think is the last thing that
makes me optimistic is
the interest alignment
between upper-income
power brokers
and lower-income kids is greater
than it's ever been before.
That wasn't there I think
in the '50s and '60s.
But today, McKinsey estimates
that we have a 3% to 5%
permanent recession
imposed on our economy,
lowering everyone's standard
of living, because of the fact
that poor kids are learning
at such lower levels
relative to their middle
and upper-income peers.
RICHARD BUERY: Yeah.
I know we're going to
have some time I think
for questions from the audience.
But can I just ask one more
question before we do that?
You are, I think,
without exaggeration,
one of the leading social
entrepreneurs in our country.
You built an amazing
organization.
Everybody is not going
to quit their career
and build an
organization like that.
So for people, not only in this
audience but out in the world,
who want to contribute to
making equal opportunity
real for children, what
does the average citizen do?
ERIC SCHWARZ: That's
a great question,
and the last chapter of
the book gets into that.
And some of it is advocating
for government to do more,
and pushing
government to do more,
and thanking government when it
does what you guys are trying
to do around extended day
and early childhood and more.
Some of it is get
directly involved.
So that could be-- we've got a
half-dozen schools here in New
York that Citizen
Schools is working with.
And we're looking for
more citizen teachers
to teach any number of things.
It doesn't have to
be rocket science.
It can be whatever
you're passionate about.
It can be the history
of blues and jazz music.
But it doesn't have to
be at Citizen Schools.
It could be at one
of the TASC schools.
It could be through MentorNet
or Big Brothers Big Sisters.
But get involved.
Or in the summer,
hire a student.
Hire a high school student.
That can be a ladder.
That creates a ladder
of opportunity.
If you don't have time to
do one of those things,
but you have a little
bit of extra money,
think about how much money
you spend on your own kids
to go to Argentina.
And say, well, maybe
I'm going to match that,
and I'm going to still
do that for my kids.
But I'm going to
take an equal amount
and give it to Citizen
Schools, or give it
to another organization
that's providing
similar things to all kids.
So I think people
need to get involved.
And it's fun.
You heard from [? Gautham. ?]
It's really fun.
The Citizen Schools
people are awesome.
You get to work with
incredibly cool people.
You learn a lot.
And it makes life
more enriching,
and it makes our country
and city stronger.
RICHARD BUERY: Great, thank you.
ERIC SCHWARZ: Thank you.
RICHARD BUERY: Let's open
up for some questions.
Do want people to use the mics?
CREW: Yes.
RICHARD BUERY: Would you mind
going to the side to the mics?
It's a race.
Who will get to the mic first?
Oh, we have a winner.
Maybe introduce yourself, too.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Linda [? Freed. ?] And
thank you to both of you
on all counts for your visionary
work and making it work.
Eric, when you're talking
about citizens taking the lead,
one of the many things that is
profoundly important about what
you're saying is the
message that all of our kids
are all of our responsibility.
And in my experience,
not everybody gets that.
And so I was wondering--
and we need to, obviously.
The people in the room get it,
clearly, because they're here.
But in your experience--
and for both of you really--
what are the ahas, the
wows, that actually
can transform one
understanding to the other?
ERIC SCHWARZ: I think
it starts with exposure.
I think human beings
learn through experience
and relationships.
And so if you only read about
kids or see stuff on TV,
you form a set of impressions.
You maybe hear
from other people.
And you don't have any chance
to combat those stereotypes.
You don't have any chance to
build empathy and build love
for kids who are different from
you or from a different ZIP
code.
So we need to find
ways to scale up
the idea of connecting people
across different lines.
And Citizens' goal is
one model for doing that.
It's not the only model, but
I think it's very important.
Robert Putnam talks
about social capital.
And to get ahead, you
need your tight circles
of the people you
go to church with,
the people in your
neighborhood who support you.
But you also need what he
calls bridging social capital
to connect with
the world outside.
And that's true for
rich people, too.
Everyone needs that
sense of connection
to folks beyond their core.
You want to--
RICHARD BUERY: Well,
no, I would agree.
It's one of the ways in which
residential and educational
segregation are so pernicious.
Because what it does, it allows
us to perpetuate the idea
that those around us are other
and different and separate.
And if people are separate, then
you have no investment in them.
So I do believe that,
ultimately, the country has
to sort of take seriously the
idea of the broader community.
I was trained as a
civil rights lawyer.
I didn't practice
very long, but I
was theoretically a
civil rights lawyer once.
And I do really
believe this work
is an extension of that work.
Because m what
we're trying to do
is to create justice
for our citizens.
But to do that, you
have to actually believe
that your neighbor
is your citizen.
And in a country like
this, and a city like this,
that can be a difficult thing.
So I do believe it's
a bedrock question.
Because how do you get people
connected in a world where
there are so many ways not
to be connected, I think
is one of the
fundamental challenges
for how do we bring to
the light the just country
that we imagine.
ERIC SCHWARZ: Well said.
RICHARD BUERY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Good evening.
My name is Diana Breen.
I'm on the board of the Cypress
Hills Childcare Corporation.
And deputy mayor,
first I just want
to congratulate you on an
ambitious rollout of UPK.
Mr. Schwarz, I was
wondering if you--
[APPLAUSE]
Yes.
And after school tomorrow.
RICHARD BUERY: I'm going
to have a bunch of drinks
right after this, by the way.
AUDIENCE: Mr. Schwarz,
I was wondering,
if you had a special Citizen
Schools time machine,
and you could go back, as you
were building the organization,
are there any
things strategically
or with programming that you
would have done differently?
ERIC SCHWARZ: That's
a cool question.
I should ask Steven
for what the answer is.
And it's kind of a
cool opportunity now
for the organization
to reinvent itself
with an amazing base of support
and take it to the next level.
One of the things I
really struggle with,
and Steven is struggling with,
and we're thinking about,
is, how do you simultaneously
build an organization
and build a movement?
And a lot of people I
think in this world,
a lot of social entrepreneurs,
think about that challenge.
And you can get trapped in
the challenges of building
your own organization and
lose sight of the movement.
But you can also just
talk about the movement
and lose sight of the results.
And I'm very proud of the
results that we've delivered,
and I'm very proud
of the contribution
we've made to a movement.
But it's at the earliest stages.
And I think with
Richard, with TASC,
with a lot of the other
people in this room,
there's potential.
And I wish I'd done even more
on this over the last 10 years
to really push hard on getting
all levels of government
to really invest in
expanded learning time
as the necessary complement to
this kind of shadow education
system that's growing up in
upper-income communities.
And it's starting to happen.
Governor Cuomo and
Governor Christie
don't agree on that
many things necessarily.
They're both putting
expanded learning time
into their budgets.
And the president is
getting behind this
in a few different ways.
More and more
school districts are
starting to think about, all
right, we need to scale this.
And if we want to ever
have a chance, a prayer,
of having our kids catch up with
their upper-income neighbors,
they're going to need more time.
They're going to
need more mentors.
need more chances
to kind of make
things and experiment.
Thank you.
RICHARD BUERY: Is that part
of the Cypress Hills Local
Development Corporation?
AUDIENCE: It's a subsidiary.
RICHARD BUERY: OK.
That's one of the most amazing
organizations in the city,
and great work.
AUDIENCE: I think so, too.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD BUERY: I think we
probably only have time
for one more maybe.
ERIC SCHWARZ: I'll
get John afterwards.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Oscar Robles.
I work for US2020, which is an
organization that was born out
of Citizen Schools
to connect 1 million
STEM-- Science,
Technology, Engineering,
and Math-- professionals to
hands-on project-based learning
for under-represented
kids in those fields.
And my question is
around-- something
I've really enjoyed reading
so far in the book, Eric, is
your incredible tenacity for
the idea of Citizen Schools.
I mean, here we
are 20 years later
after you started the idea
in your basement, really.
So I would love to hear a
little bit about the grit
that it took to keep Citizen
Schools alive at times
when it was really difficult
for social entrepreneurs
like myself.
And with US2020, we're
just a year and a half out.
How did you keep
the vision in mind,
keep the folks who
were doing the work
on the ground impassioned
toward that vision,
and be able to get
it to where it's
grown now here 20 years later?
ERIC SCHWARZ:
Well, thanks Oscar.
And this US2020
is a good example
of Citizen Schools helping
to sort of lead a movement,
and working closely with
the White House and others
on this, to get a million
science, technology,
engineering, and math folks
out there working at Citizen
Schools, but also working at
TASC, and working in schools,
and working at Girl Scouts,
and all kinds of places.
So that's awesome, and thank
you Oscar for your work on that.
For me, it's been
a labor of love.
It's really awesome
seeing your baby grow up.
And at every step
of the way, that's
been a personal kind of
heart feeling I've had.
On hard days, I remember
in the beginning,
my kind of go-to plan was
to go talk to a parent.
And I remember the first
summer it was like 95 degrees.
We were in a school
in Dorchester.
Richard, you've probably
been in the school.
It's actually where
Yasminia went to school.
And no air conditioning, school
is under construction-- there's
broken glass all over the place.
It was 98 degrees inside
and outside day after day.
And I think we were making a
lot of headway with the kids,
but sometimes it
wasn't so clear.
And when I had hard
days, I would go talk
to some parents, who would
often pick up their kids at 6:00
at the end of the day.
It was a full-day
summer program.
And always, even if
it seemed tough to us,
they were so proud
and so excited.
And they were so thrilled
to see their kids
working with engineers, and
working with filmmakers,
and working with journalists
and lawyers and carpenters.
And so that really fed
me in a powerful way.
I taught seven apprenticeships.
So I taught journalism
in the beginning.
But my dad's a lawyer, so I
argued a lot around the dining
room table and never went into
law like you and like dad.
But I taught a couple mock
trial classes, taught a business
class, and that kept me
close to the action as well.
But it's been incredible.
And this book--
last thing I'll say
before you just sort of
close it down for the night.
This book has been a
labor of love, too.
Because I've worked on it
over the last couple years.
It was a gift to be
able to finish it right
as I was passing
the baton to Steven
and preparing to start a
new nonprofit in the higher
education world.
It's a gift to be able to tell
the story of Citizen Schools,
tell a little bit of
my own personal story,
but really tell a
story about what
I think is going on in the
country, what's really causing
this growing achievement gap--
it's very different from what
a lot of people think--
and hopefully give people
some confidence that we don't
have to accept that status quo.
There's actually
lots of examples--
Citizens was a great one--
of how we can come together
as a country in
very affordable ways
to lift up opportunity
for all kids.
And so last plug for the
book-- they have a lot of them
out there.
Google subsidized the price.
They're only $10.
You can buy them to give
to friends and to family,
as well as take
one for yourself.
And there's a great local
bookstore, McNally Jackson,
that's here.
And I'm donating all author
proceeds to Citizen Schools.
So thank you so much for coming.
Thank you to Google for hosting.
And Richard, thank you for
being a great partner up here.
This is awesome.
RICHARD BUERY: Thank you.
Yeah, let me just say,
just to wrap up again,
really do buy the book,
"The Opportunity Equation,"
"Opportunity Equation."
And as Eric said, proceeds do
go towards Citizen Schools.
And it's hard to imagine
a better investment
than the organization
Citizen Schools.
I want to thank you
for your leadership,
for your leadership
in this work,
for your dedication to
our country's future.
And thank you for helping
to inspire all of us
to be better citizens.
It's my honor to be
your friend, and I
can't wait to see what
happens next in your career.
Thank you.
ERIC SCHWARZ: Awesome.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]